voir donc à des agriculteurs vigilants
et si vous avez session prévention chez
cet agriculteur de marmagne face aux
incivilités dans les exploitations
agricoles la gendarmerie veillent au
grain je pense que c'est une bonne chose
puisque ça nous permet d'être suivie de
pouvoir
éventuellement dire ce qui est un
problème ou si on voit des choses ce qui
se passe on ne ferme donc je pense que
c'est une très très bonne chose le
réseau agriculteurs vigilant est un
échange entre gendarmes et agriculteurs
d'un côté les forces de l'ordre donnent
des conseils en matière de sécurité
de l'autre les exploitants signale le
moindre fait suspect les vols sont les
délits les plus courants là aujourd'hui
on arrive sur des vols qui deviennent
beaucoup plus organisée vraiment ça
devient du banditisme quand c'est des
réseaux qui vole une dizaine
d'équipements gps dans une même nuit
épique après derrière sa destinée à des
réseaux de revente ailleurs ou sur du
gasoil aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec
des fermes qui sont vides et 7,8 milles
dit de fioul en une nuit
en cas de vol dans leur secteur les
exploitants sont prévenus par sms
le réseau peut désormais compter sur 90
agriculteurs vigilant concrètement
lorsque la personne l'agriculteur s'est
inscrit dans le dispositif
elle est enregistrée l accès à une
messagerie qui s'appelle chapin qui est
une messagerie proposée par l'état et
qui permet de recevoir de l'information
descendants il ya aussi un procédé qui a
été validé et vu que la chambre
d'agriculture qui est un envoi de sms
qui interviendra voilà de façon assez
épisodique dans l'année lorsque un
événement majeur et qu'on a besoin
d'informer tout de suite nos
agriculteurs ils vont recevoir un sms
ce système a déjà porté ses fruits l'an
dernier notamment dans une affaire de
mutilation de chevaux pour dénoncer des
comportements suspects le réseau
agriculteurs vigilant devrait trouver
d'autres volontaires parmi les trois
mille cinq cents exploitations du
département du cher